I've now traveling through the franconia
region in northern bavaria but i can't
get into the swing of things and revive
my old motivation scoot push scoot push
pause scoop push these last seven weeks
have really exhausted me I finally
reached Bavaria but the state is large
and there are still a lot of distance
left for me to cover I'm in beautiful
Chanel under blend and I'm exactly 1404
clicks and 47 days from my starting
point on zilch I have 33 days to reach
haledon Vanga egg in the south sure no
underpin doesn't sound like much of a
town just like many other places I have
visited on my tour but just like them it
really does have something special to
offer an invention that has changed the
world was made here in the 1920s this is
where are Toph I invented what's called
the German gymnastics wheel it can be
used for sports or even circuses of
course it appears in the town's coat of
arms and there's even a monument
dedicated to this magnificent invention
ask the locals if they've ever used to
gymnastics wheel and just about everyone
says yes when they were children and
they enjoyed it sure this man says it
was an uplifting experience I didn't but
another says he tried it once fell on
his back and never touched one again
good it looks as if everyone in schönau
has tried a German gym wheel I have
certainly called German wheel fever now
I want to discover my hidden talent but
my first challenge is to find one of
those contractions ready
good what I'm looking for a gym wheel do
you have one do you have a gym wheel I
can try out I ask this woman if all the
people here have gym wheels in their
living rooms she says they do that they
grow up with them but she doesn't have
one with her no finally someone points
the way and this woman doesn't have one
herself but she tells me to go to the
Sports Center that's the decisive tip
why does so few people do wheel
gymnastics it's unanimous vinegaroon
daytona line here so now Humbert Isaac
turn on the phone since it's in vid conf
gonna
bomb twin white wheel gymnastics it's
such a strange piece of equipment that's
just what's so fascinating about it the
wheel is a piece of equipment that moves
on its own and while it's moving the
gymnast also has to move at least wheel
gymnastics looks a lot more elegant than
kicking a scooter as the home of this
sport Germany is the world's biggest gym
wheel nation there are just under seven
thousand active wheel gymnasts and the
Germans are very successful in
international tournaments they win about
three-quarters of the medals I want to
demonstrate my skill it can't be that
hard with the wheel turning 360 degrees
it's a bit like being weightless this
hamster wheel exercise almost makes me
want to bite the wheel and sit on top of
it while it's turning help get me down
okay wheel gymnastics is harder than I
thought and takes a bit of practice so
there's nothing left for me to do but
get back on my good old scooter this
time it's go west young man
you